an arrest report describes some of the
final moments of a five-year-old boy's
life
his babysitter accused of killing him
the i-team's vanessa murphy first broke
the story on tuesday and now she has
much more now we do want to warn you
some of the details in this report are
rather disturbing
[Music]
many viewers have responded to this
story some have donated to two gofundme
accounts
set up for the child's family now right
now 22 year old
lauren courtney remains in custody here
at the clark county detention
center facing charges for first degree
murder and child abuse
we've learned a key piece of evidence in
this case
is video metro police say courtney was
the babysitter for
five-year-old ryan james peralta and his
seven-year-old sister
according to an arrest report the dad
installed cameras
after the sister said courtney hurt ryan
detectives call the footage horrendous
and say courtney is seen dragging ryan
while he was limp
kicking him in the head dropping him so
his head hit the bathroom floor
punching him in the face and dragging
him into the shower turning on the water
while the child moaned in pain ryan died
the next day
ryan's dad says he found courtney by
word of mouth
police say she told him she previously
advertised on care.com
a spokeswoman for the website tells the
i-team she has not been
active for two years according to the
website
background checks are done for
caregivers but those results are not
made public
and it is recommended for parents and
guardians to do their own
background checks as for courtney she's
set to be back in court in may
vanessa murphy 8 news now